[Music]
imagine if you woke up one day and
you're fired based bill went from zero
to thirty thousand US dollars well
that's exactly what happened to a
start-up in Colombia that scaled up to
about two million daily active users
they really just made one seemingly
minor mistake and with this video I want
to show you how we can take their thirty
thousand dollar bill and reduce it down
to about twenty five bucks if you're new
to the channel make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and you can grab the source
code for this project at angular
firebase com
so you may have already seen this
article because it kind of went viral
last week on hacker noon but the source
of this hi Bill was because they managed
to make over 40 billion requests to
firestore in less than 48 hours so how
is that even possible when you only have
two million users that means every user
would have to make about twenty thousand
document reads the mistake they made is
that they needed to calculate the total
for every crowdfunding campaign but they
were doing this by reading every single
document in a collection for every user
on the site so as they got more users
and more payments the problem just
compounded to result in a shitload of
document reads not only is that super
expensive but it also results in a lot
of latency on the client and that's
actually how they discovered the problem
in the first place and I should also
point out that this type of mistake is
very common and you really won't notice
it until you start scaling up in users
and you run into these problems with
billing and performance I'm gonna show
you how to avoid this with strategies
both client-side and server-side but the
number one thing you should do right off
the bat is setup a billing alert on
Google cloud platform every firebase
project is tied to a GCP project so you
just have to go into the billing panel
and then setup the billing thresholds
that you want to be alerted on so that
way you can find out early if you have
some kind of issue that's resulting in
billing spikes but that doesn't really
solve the problem at hand because the
problem is in the code so I set up a
demo here that does something similar
basically it calculates the total amount
of donations the average amount of each
donation and this is all based on a fire
store collection but I have this app
super poorly optimized where I'm reading
every document in the collection three
separate times one for the total one for
the average and then one to show the
list of donations so this collection has
one
documents in it it will take 300
document reads to present the UI that
you see on the left believe it or not
this is pretty easy to do and it still
performs great at this level so you
really wouldn't notice an issue at this
point the startup in the article was
using angular so we'll be doing the same
here we'll be using firestore with
angular fire - and then i'm importing
fakers so i can generate some fake data
for the UI now the first thing i want to
show you is how we can optimize things
client-side and i think that's really
where you should focus first so we have
three different observables here one for
the donations one for the total amount
and one for the average amount so the
mistake that I'm making here first is
that I'm creating a separate observable
for the same collection to show all
three of these different amounts that
means that we're going to subscribe to
three different observables fire off
three separate read operations to fire
store even though they all depend on the
same source data I'm not really going to
explain this code in detail but
basically what we're doing is taking the
fire store collection which is an array
and then we reduce it down to the total
amount of all of the donations in that
collection and then we do the same thing
for the average with just a slightly
different calculation and then we
subscribe to all three of these
observables in the HTML using the async
pipe so the main problem here is that we
have three different data sources that
are being created even though we could
really get this all done with a single
data source so let's take a look at how
we might use rxjs
to reduce our document reads down from
about 300 to 100 what we want to do is
have one observable that can be shared
with the other observables that make the
calculation for the total in the average
so what I'm going to do first is pipe in
the top operator so we can see when a
subscription is created to this
observable then we'll also console.log
the number of documents to get an
approximate amount of the reads that
were executed so now instead of having
the total and the average create their
own observables we'll just go ahead and
use the donations observable that we
created above so let's take a look and
see if that actually solved the problem
in the UI we should only get one
console.log but if we look closely here
we're still getting three side-effects
which should mean that we're sending off
three sets of reads to firestore luckily
there's an easy way to fix this with
rxjs and that's just by pi
being in the [ __ ] replay operator which
will make this a hot observable and
allow any other subscribers to always
get the last cached value so now we can
be a hundred percent confident that our
code is only sending off one document
read to the backend so that can be a
super useful technique and you can also
use an angular service to inject the
same data source into multiple
components but the actual problem that
was faced by the startup is that we need
all of the information from every
document in that collection and to do
that client-side means that we would
have to read every single document every
time which is just not feasible but we
can implement a server-side solution to
make this way more efficient and we can
do it with firebase cloud functions an
app like this is very heavy on document
reads but very light on document writes
for example we might have a hundred
people visit the page but only one of
those people actually make a donation
and write something to the database one
of the main reasons that no sequel
database is like fire stores so popular
is that we have the flexibility to
optimize for read performance what we're
going to do next is set up a cloud
function that listens to the donation
collection and every time a new document
is written there it will update an
aggregated document that contains the
total count the total amount and also
the last five donations that were left
so this means we could have a million
documents in our donations collection
and have all the information needed for
the front-end UI with a single document
read the actual data payload will now be
much smaller so our front-end UI is
going to be way more performant for 99%
of users and basically what we're doing
is trading 20,000 client-side document
reads for an extra write and an extra
cloud function invocation in this case
that's an excellent trade-off and it'll
make the pricing go from 30k down to
pretty close to the free tier one of the
drawbacks is that it makes writes to the
UI a little bit slower because we have
to wait for that cloud function to
finish before the document is updated
but in this case it makes a ton of sense
because the vast majority of users are
reading data and not changing it I have
initialized firebase cloud functions in
this project and I'm also using the new
node 8 runtime which allows me to use
async await in just a plain JavaScript
function
we'll bring in the admin database and
then we'll want to listen to every new
donation document that is created in
that fire store collection when a new
document is created we'll just want to
update the aggregated data for that
collection so we're no longer displaying
the actual donation documents but
instead we're displaying the aggregated
document based on that collection there
is no best practice for this but
generally what I do is I save a document
in a collection called aggregation and
the ID for that document matches the
collection that were making calculations
on and you really just want to save the
bare minimum amount of information you
need to make calculations in the UI in
our case we just need to show the
average and the total so we can
calculate these by taking the current
aggregated total and then add it to the
amount of the new donation and then we
can take the total count and just add
one to it and then we'll also save the
last five donations we can show those in
the view as well by saving the last five
donations here we can show those in the
view and we'll only have to execute one
document read instead of five which can
make a pretty big difference if you have
two million users and then we'll
complete our function by just returning
a set operation from it and we're good
to get all our front-end UI looks
exactly like it did before but instead
we're just doing a single document read
instead of say twenty thousand the nice
thing about firestore is that it's easy
to anticipate your pricing let's imagine
that every user reads about ten
documents per visit that would be about
20 million document reads per 2 million
users or about $25 per 2 million
sessions or savings of about 99.9% from
the startups initial query setup I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to learn how
to get a quality app shipped to
production consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get a free copy my book access to my
courses and a whole bunch of other free
stuff thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you soon